or is one of the genres most often
maligned by critics on one hand that's
because a lot of horror movies are
pretty awful and they earn their bad
reviews but there are also plenty of
great horror films that happen to be
critical failures the average viewer
might avoid some of these movies for
their low Rotten Tomatoes scores but
that number can be deceiving here are
just a few of horror cinemas critical
failures that are actually worth your
time Lords of Salem while 2013's Lords
of Salem might not reach the levels of
exploitation nirvana that director Rob
Zombie achieved in the Devil's Rejects
it's perhaps his most interesting
project
the surreal tale of a woman who finds
herself in the snares of a centuries in
the making plot initiated by a coven of
witches
[Music]
critics slapped it with a low rating on
Rotten Tomatoes complaining that it
failed to deliver the scares that seemed
a promise to be fair that's not an
incorrect observation relatively free of
gore the film is instead something of an
experimental tone peace resulting in a
hypnotic atmospheric film that sure to
unsettle and intrigued viewers willing
to embrace abstract thrills dead silence
considering the fact that James wants
filmography contains classics like saw
insidious and the conjuring if dead
silence is known as his worst film
that's still not too much of a knock
while far from perfect it utilizes the
classic horror technique of taking
things that are already frightening in
real life in this case ventriloquist's
and their terrifying puppets and then
making them sources of actual
supernatural phenomena even a middling
horror movie is going to be pretty scary
when the protagonist is facing a ghost
ventriloquist who cuts the tongues out
of her victims all things considered
it's admittedly not anything special in
terms of plot or writing which is likely
why it didn't stick with the critics who
gave it such a low rating on Rotten
Tomatoes
but boasting some great production
design a perfectly solid cast and a
killer twist ending dead silence is
still a fun little entry in the
filmography of a director who has helped
shape mainstream horror over the last
decade all the boys love Mandy Lane
occasionally a movies poor rotten tomato
score is less indicative of a lack of
quality and more of an indicator of a
film's divisive miss among these films
is all the boys love Mandy Lane which
according to the Washington Post was
shot in 2006 and then delayed for seven
years
it's a polarizing effort that boasts a
critical reception split almost down the
middle detractors felt it was nothing
more than a run-of-the-mill slasher
movie while fans of the film praised its
innovative visuals and storytelling
restraint the story centers around a
group of teens who invite the super
popular Mandy Lane to a secluded ranch
for a weekend getaway and quickly find
themselves being picked off one by one
by a deranged stalker the movie seems to
take no delight in its kills instead
making the audience recognize the
gravity of each even if you find the
movie to be a failure it's an
interesting one for sure
Jennifer's Body there's something to be
said for a movie that knows what it is
in the 2009 horror op Jennifer's Body
knows exact
what it is the kind of film you'd watch
with your friends late at night it tells
the story of a rock band satanic ritual
gone wrong leaving high school it girl
Jennifer possessed by a demon that feeds
on the flesh of men
Jennifer's evil eye no no I mean she's
actually evil not high school evil
featuring a stellar cast the most
quotable horror movie script in decades
and a killer soundtrack it's some of the
most fun you can have watching a modern
horror movie I am NOT insecure media God
that's a joke how could I ever be
insecure I was a snowflake Queen
unfortunately critics weren't quite sure
what to make of it in 2009 and it's got
a bummer of a rotten tomato score
Jennifer's body isn't quite old enough
to have built up a cult following or to
have received a critical reevaluation
but we get the feeling that's coming
this flick like a fine wine will only
get better with age Nightbreed
advertised as a traditional slasher film
Nightbreed confused critics by giving
the audience a dark horror fantasy that
feels more like a great young adult
novel that's not to say it's skimps on
the scares it just happens to also
contain the world building and character
art you'd find in blockbuster franchises
these days the story focuses on the
human world clashing with an underground
city the home of the undead creatures
known as the night breed
for me too
[Music]
the film came out about 20 years too
early and it found itself in the hands
of critics who weren't quite sure what
to make of it violet sits with a
terrible rating on Rotten Tomatoes
Nightbreed is still very much worth your
time it's fun innovative and totally
singular